[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe gefühlt schon eine million
mal buchteln gemacht und auch gezeigt
und auch in meinen büchern
aber ich habe tatsächlich noch nie das
klassische buch dort rezept für euch
gefilmt und da bekomme ich wirklich
immer ziemlich viele nachfragen und das
ist halt immer so sally wie machst du
sie wie viele punkte brauche ich für
welches blech und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht heute gibt es klassische
buchteln die bestehen aus einem super
lockeren luftigen hefeteig für den ich
einen würfel hefe brauche 20 gramm
wasser 80 gramm zucker ein halbes kilo
mehl also 500 gramm einen teelöffel salz
250 gramm warme milch 2 eigelbe und 120
com weicher butter der mit zuerst in
würfel hefe und gebt den hier ein
ihr könnt natürlich auch halben hövel
nehmen und last am dafür aber den teig
länger aufgehen aber ein würfel hefe ist
für mich das ok zucker mit rein und
jetzt kurz die hefe mit dem zucker und
wasser verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen einfach die restlichen
zutaten rein da einfach nur darauf
achten dass salz und fett nicht direkt
mit hefe in verbindung kommen denn dann
geht der teig nicht so gut auf also
falls ihr mal das problem hat kann es
wohl möglich daran liegen oder daran
dass sie hierfür schlecht war
ihr könnt auch eure hilfe testen indem
ihr dieses hefe wasser zucker gemisch
einfach abdeckt und etwa 15 minuten
aufgehen lässt und wenn sich dann was
tut also sich so blumer bläschen bilden
und die hefe aufgeht ist sie perfekt
wenn sich dann noch nichts tut
vielleicht noch mal 15 minuten aufgehen
lassen an einem weiteren ort und wenn
sich dann immer noch nichts tut dann ist
die hefe vielleicht nicht mehr so gut
also können dass er wirklich immer
testen und habe dann gewissheit dass
euer hefeteig was wird ich gebe es das
salz aufs mail
die milch dazu und zum schluss das fett
also die weiche butter und ich bin
meistens sogar dinkelmehl 630 oder
einfach ganz normales weizenmehl 405 und
es kann einfach sein das ihr bis zu 30
40 gramm mehr oder weniger mehl braucht
und ich entscheide es aber immer dann
wenn ich schon eine weile geknetet habe
das einfach keinen so weichert eick aber
auch kein harter teig entsteht um lieber
bisschen weniger mehl benutzen und
später dazufügen als einen zu harten
hätte hefeteig zu kneten
ich könnte jetzt hier ihr können aber
auch gern per hand kneten einfach für
etwa sieben bis zehn minuten
ich gebe hier noch direkter dazu 34 grad
dann geht das schon mal bisher auf und
wird schön warm
und ich räume sollen
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt hier meine silikon matte
der teig ist perfekt geworden nicht so
weit nicht so fest und ich brauche jetzt
auch gar kein mehl mal zusätzlich wobei
es anfangs echt so ausgesehen hat aber
durch das lange kneten verspielt sich
das wirklich mal so schön weich da fest
sein und den vorsitz sich schnell zu
einer kugel
das war's schon jetzt die schüssel
fetten den teig reinlegen und die
oberfläche fetten damit sie auch nicht
austrocknet beim aufgehen und entweder
lasst ihr den teil geht's einfach bei
raumtemperatur abgedeckt aufgehen oder
im backofen bei der stufe weil sich so
die bank die derzeit einfach um die
hälfte verkürzt
[Musik]
mein tag ist wunderbar aufgegangen
in kürzester zeit zum fertig stellen
brauche ich jetzt noch etwas butter die
buchteln sind einfach gut wenn sie mit
reichlich butter gemacht werden dann
schmecken uns auch am nächsten und sogar
am übernächsten tag noch gut obwohl bei
uns selten der fall ist das übrig
bleiben und ich will sie am liebsten mit
aprikosen oder marillenmarmelade bei mir
ist es sogar eine premiere denn ich habe
einen baum
den hat mir der christian damals
empfohlen von lebensraum müller das ist
die apathie heißt sie ab primera
aprikose mirabelle gekreuzt damit ich
einfach die besten früchte habt der
stein löst sich super ab und daraus
mache ich gern meine marmelade
die habe ich jetzt hier immer mit mandel
extrakt natürlich und für die menge also
für diese fünf und dort kam nehme ich
mein kleinstes fuchtel blech also mein
kleinstes ofen blech da fragen auch
immer viele danach denn da könnt ihr im
prinzip euch wirklich an den blechen
orientieren das gleich mit 28
zentimetern durchmesser ist für diese
menge perfekt also für 500 gramm mehl
das blech mit 22 32 cm durchmesser ist
für 750 gramm mehl und es blech mit 36
zentimetern durchmesser für ein kilo
mehl also da könnt ihr euch dann
wirklich sagen kleines blech buchte
mittleres blech oder großes blech und
dann passt immer perfekt was hier ganz
gut ist ich geb die butter hier rein und
kann sie direkt im blech schmelzen
einfach auf dem herd weil wirklich die
bleche auch induktion geeignet sind
gehen natürlich auf einem ganz normalen
zellen oder kochfeld jetzt einfach super
stufe eins so bisschen die butter
schmelzen und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit wenn die buchteln formen
da mache ich normalerweise mittlerweile
so dass ich einfach den teig
herausnehmen form und direkt in die
formel 1 gebe aber damit er es besser
trainieren können könnte das auch gerne
raus nehmen den teig einteilen
aber so mit der zeit und im dritten
vierten fünften mal buchteln machen hat
man es dann auch raus wie groß sie sein
müssen und dann kann man es auch direkt
ohne mathe aus der form in die form
machen und schwarze ich noch ein
bisschen geschämt
also ich mache jetzt hier etwa 15 stück
[Musik]
nämlich so ein kleines stückchen und
öffne ist in meiner hand nicht so groß
damit einfach der teig nicht zu dünn
wird und beim zusammendrücken dann
bleibt beschreibt also das ist
eigentlich das was die meisten falsch
machen mir auch samira zum beispiel wenn
ich jetzt sage ich man nicht so groß
eröffnen damit der teig nicht dünn und
rissig wird und dann jetzt hier entweder
mit einem teelöffel oder mit dem
kleinsten 1 portionierer die menge
rausnehmen dann nehme ich jetzt schon so
einen gehäuften als portionierer soll
jetzt mal ganz schnell arbeiten damit
die marmelade nicht nach außen fließt
ich nehme erst die gegenüberliegenden
seiten und wegen wirklich ganz
vorsichtig mit den fingerspitzen drücke
ich die bucht und zusammen und deswegen
auch hier kein mädel benutzen damit der
teig sofort klebt und guckt mal
ich muss gar nichts machen und die
buchten ist schon perfekt rund wenn ihr
wollt können dass er noch umdrehen mit
der naht nach unten und dann aber schon
direkt ins blech setzen
[Musik]
wenn ihr das in der hand nicht formen
könnt könnt ihr es auch gerne unten
ablegen
dann könne nicht mit beiden fingern
sozusagen zupfen und einfach wie so ein
kleines säckchen verschließen und
perfekt
[Musik]
ich liebe worte
guck mal ich bestreite jetzt auch die
buchteln direkt mit der butter und im
prinzip ist nur wichtig dass wirklich
rundherum butter ist dann kriegt er zum
einen die bucht und später schön von
einander abgelöst
sie schmeckt halt besser der teig da ist
so luftig geworden dass die praktisch
während ich sie formel sofort weiter
aufgeht
deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht mehr
direkt rein gelegt sondern dann wirklich
gewahrt wird
ich hätte nur noch gern 1 2 in der mitte
und jetzt hier die butter nehmen
schön bestreichen und jetzt können dass
sie im prinzip noch einmal aufgehen
lassen abgedeckt aber ich muss sagen
dass der teig immer so mega luftig ist
ich gebe den einfach das ganze blech in
den kalten backofen schallt dann den
ofen ein wenn ihr wollt noch dampf stufe
1 muss aber nicht sein
dadurch gehen sie noch mal extreme auf
und dann einfach backen oder verlängert
sich die backzeit zogen fünf bis zehn
minuten nur im vergleich zu dessen wenn
man praktisch sie in den heißen ofen
gibt aber ich finde das spart man sich
einfach so eine gute halbe stunde an
aufgezeigt
[Musik]
30 minuten waren perfekt ich habe
allerdings nach 15 minuten den dampf
ausgemacht denn die buchteln sind jetzt
schon perfekt aufgegangen
sie guckt ihr euch angetan es ist
einfach wunderschön dass ich sie ganz
kurz abkühlen und dann werden sie mit
süßem schnee bestreut oder mit glitzer
schnee und dann serviert
[Musik]
ich benutze da muss ich echt zeigen ganz
gerne glitzer schnee weil es einfach
eine tolle alternative zur butter zucker
ist und vor allem hat man einfach diese
schöne glitzer optik die ihr jetzt
vielleicht steht die kamera gar nicht so
seht aber hier so im wahren leben in
meiner küche es glitzert einfach es
sieht wunderschön aus und man hat
einfach nicht so süß wie wenn man jetzt
puderzucker drauf streut
alternativ könnt ihr auch süßen schlee
verwenden dass es auch in puderzucker
der nicht schmilzt auf der oberfläche
also auch nicht auf warmem gebäck oder
auf creme und sahne genauso wie geht's
aus schnee bleibt schön auf der
oberfläche stehen man hat die optik und
wirklich nicht zusätzlich nochmal gesüßt
[Musik]
die buchteln werden gleich probiert von
dem karaoke trio
ich möchte sie euch gerne schon einmal
vorstellen hey ich bin sally kommt das
ist beirat das ist julia und wir sind
das trio ohne namen
das wären da noch die weißen das trio
das trio wie heißt das trio
[Musik]
entschuldigung habt ihr schon mal solche
weichen fluffigen luftigen buchteln
gesehen
die glitzern die glitzern nein nein du
ja ja das ausgehobene fotografiert nein
jedoch sei auch schon mein gott ihr
müsst euch jetzt nur eine teilen denn
wir machen gleich noch fotos
sag mal nachdenkt drin von der marmelade
zustande weil da war eine marmelade sie
hat noch vom winter das hat sie mit zimt
um die andere dass wir sind jetzt
richtig überzeugt heute nun dann stimmt
es generell die luft durch von daher
nicht sagt mal war es milder
vorher kann es ja weihnachtlich ja weil
die einen da habt ihr praktisch immer
genau die erwischt mit der weihnachts
marmelade egal ich wollte praktisch
resteverwertung machen
sie können das ab weil ich schon wieder
da noch die alte marmelade rein
ja aber man sieht ja im winter macht man
mal laden die hält ewig mit dem ganzen
zu kommen ist halt so was er übrigens
auch machen könnt wenn ihr keine
marmelade mit haut einfach nougat rein
joachim logisch auch dem zar peter
magath creme also nur gattin buchte ist
auch immer der oberhammer
ich hatte auch schon harmon füllung und
so aber so marmelade nougat sind für
mich meine lieblingsfilme von stufe in
welche führen
ich möchte mal was herzhaftes okay sie
kriegt noch ihre herzhaften buchteln mit
aioli die versprechen ich jetzt schon
seit drei jahre habe ich meine taktik
ist praktisch ich habe julia hierher
geholt hat ich hab's ja genau
und sie sagt ja die ganze last buchte
mit aioli bevorstehe also geht es den
etat müsse frei bleiben
viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal
jetzt habe ich einfach ich mach dir
buchteln mit aioli wollte ja auch
herzhafte buchteln wollte danach drückte
ich hatte so ich will auch okay
[Musik]